let's head over to Victoria Saha she
spoke to those who first noticed the and
made at large and called police Victoria
hey Kirsten to give you an idea of just
how close Duarte Herrera was to leaving
this country he was just minutes away
from getting on the 10 p.m shuttle right
here by Owens and Stevens that's what
officers swarmed the building here after
someone recognized him
convicted murderer Porfirio Duarte
Herrera isn't dressed like he had been
on the run for nearly five days when he
walked through the doors of Las Vegas
shuttles he like tried to avoid eye
contact and he was a little bit like
silent trying to just answer the
necessary questions Gabriel Delgadillo
manages the bus station where shuttles
to Tijuana run twice a day it was his
front desk dispatch that recognized
Duarte Herrera Wednesday night because
police were there earlier with his
picture she knew the face because the
police had already taken this flyer with
his mug shot and basically he asked us
to be on the lookout what they didn't
realize is that Duarte Herrera actually
came in the day before on Tuesday
afternoon to buy his ticket video
revealing him showing an ID and paying
in cash he wanted to travel on Tuesday
and he probably couldn't because we were
already fully booked the time stamp on
the video shows Tuesday around 1 1 40 PM
less than an hour after Nevada
Department of Corrections announced the
inmate had escaped and later said he was
last accounted for on Friday you can see
in surveillance video Duarte Herrera
comes back Wednesday evening with gray
jeans a backpack and a hat checking in
for his bus him using some ID that was
a literally like further footing ID and
looked quite new so she that made her
believe that you know he was sketchy
this is when the front desk alerted
Delgadillo who called 9-1-1 well it's
more of a risk that I don't do it Duarte
Herrera notices Police pull up he goes
to the other side of the building and
brushes past the Metro officer then just
as he was about to board onto the
shuttle he's arrested would you consider
your dispatcher a hero of course yeah we
do
and our workers at this bus station say
they've been watching the news coverage
about this so they knew they had to be
on the lookout but the name that police
gave them didn't match anyone on their
ticket list but there's so many
questions about this where do you get
the money where do you get the clothes
well one-way ticket to Tijuana Mexico
here cost a hundred and one dollars
Kirsten and Victoria that worker
mentioned the woman said that the ID
looked a little bit sketchy we know that
this inmate is known to have used
aliases in the past was that the same
case here
yeah that's what the worker that you
just heard from he told me that the ID
that he presented it said Eric Martinez
Kirsten great thank you so very much
Victoria great reporting we appreciate
that